hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast investigated in vitro drug
toxicology with human IPSC derived
cardiomyocytes I'm Judy or arc of
leopards and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab routes comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by cellular
dynamics international the largest
producer of human induced pluripotent
stem cell tissue cells from non clinical
and clinical populations you probably
start there are few instructions we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment answers are welcome
to you can do this by hitting the green
QA button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
we don't have time today want a better
look you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome dr. Blake Anson product manager
at cellular dynamics international and
dr. Matt Brock scientific manager
investigative toxicology and safety
assessment Genentech I will now turn it
over to our speakers all right thank you
Judy Thank You Julie and welcome
everybody we um as I said we're going to
be talking about investigative and vitro
drug toxicology testing with human IPSC
derived cardiomyocytes it'll be a
two-part presentation and the first part
will be myself giving really an overview
of the individual reagent I saw
cardiomyocytes human stem cell-derived
cardiomyocytes I'll then go in and talk
a little bit about some advancements
that we've made on the cardiomyocytes
are second-generation product
as well as a little bit of serum-free
recording conditions that we've just
recently developed so in terms of an
overview for my portion of the talk here
briefly give an overview of the company
structure how we manufacture the cells
and in our product portfolio then morph
into the overview of the iso
cardiomyocytes and ways that they can be
used in toxicity testing that as
mentioned i'll go into a couple of
recent advancements and then I'll turn
it over to dr. Matthew Brock who will
talk about how Genentech is actually
using these cells and and their broader
view on testing in each or toxicity all
right so cellular dynamics okay where
the world's largest producer of human
iPS cells and the tissue cells derived
from those cells as you can see on the
slide here I've split this out into two
different areas our infrastructure and
our competencies and so the left-hand
side the infrastructure is meant to show
you that we are well enabled to do what
we do and the competencies are thus
meant to show you that we can do when
I'm tell you we can do so from an
infrastructure side we're about 160
people and we've got really distinct rd
process science and manufacturing teams
so rd developed protocols process
science scales them up and manufacture
just turn the crank and turns out that
product we've got an extensive amount of
experience in stem cell biology we're
headquartered in Madison Wisconsin but
we serve and support the global market
and as you can see we've got a good
handle on an incredibly complex IP
landscape so we're able to do what we do
and customers are able to do to use the
cells our competency is really fourfold
here is the creation and culture of stem
cells so that would be reprogramming
and then this basically cell culture
husbandry we can also genetically
engineer these lines or these cells to
help in the differentiation so put in
selection engineering or also put in
various pathway or marker specific
markers we continually are developing
new stem cell cell types we can do that
across all three germ layers and last
but not least is then translating that
that research into large-scale
production so we can get them out into
the customer base for use right at a
real high level really going to take
advantage or meet several requirements
to take advantage of the stem cell
technology and those requirements for a
burly a scale-up are going to be a very
tight differentiation manufacturing
specifications we move this from a
science fair experiment into an
industrialized manufacturing system and
its really relies on a strong quality
management system as mentioned before we
have the ability to g4g no modification
and again this is really essential to
take full advantage of the ipsc
technology and also we have to be able
to scale up this process and we've
really been able to do that we see on
the right-hand side there a little
window of our scale up manufacturing
benchmarks where we can really
manufacture any of our cell types and
billions of cells which is meant to
fully enable any type of screening
project the gross arrow a diagram there
that's in the center of the screen
really out lies how we do the
manufacturing that as we create a bank a
specific Bank of stem cells each time we
go to manufacture a new batch of
terminal cells such as cardiomyocytes we
would then expand an aliquot from that
working bank differentiate the cells
purify QC them and then store them so
they're ready to ship so again this is
not made to order
this is you order and we ship right away
when we need to make additional batches
of cells we go back that same starting
material so there is no variability
there based on donors no unwanted
variability all right the next part of
taking advantage of the ipsc technology
is to be able to scale out so we have to
scale up make a lot of the cells from an
individual donor we have to be able to
make cells from multiple donors hundreds
if not thousands of donors and we've
also really crack the nut on that so we
can do parallel derivation and
differentiation from multiple donors and
the bubble on the right-hand side now is
just two examples of the scale or
capabilities we are finishing up a grant
now where we are supplying approximately
250 batches of cardiomyocytes that have
been reprogrammed from 250 different
donors that had varying levels of left
ventricular hypertrophy this is part of
an NHLBI study that will really further
the GOS correlation between genome-wide
sequence variations and functional
outcomes we're also involved in a
California Institute of Medicine grant
where we are generating 9,000 clones
across 3,000 individuals these
individuals will be from 11 different
disease types as well as a variety of
control populations so we're well-versed
in generating a lot of cells from a lot
of donors we really applied this
technology then to our product portfolio
as shown here on this slide the products
the I sell products are listed on the
left hand side and these are simple
off-the-shelf standard in vitro stem
cell models so whether it's
cardiomyocytes neuronal lineages blood
lineages skeletal myoblasts these are I
guess we could call our vanilla
I PS seen dr tissue cells the middle
column here exemplifies and provide some
examples from our diversity and disease
portfolio so here we're taking samples
and making cells from donors that
incorporate disease and diversity so the
first part of diversity is to get a
variety of both male and female donors
into into our production scheme we've
also then branching out further into
various diseases in cardiomyocytes
neurons and parasites we've got a little
bit of a coming soon blurb there on the
bottom that's simply to exemplify that
this is continually expanding and so
contact your rep contact CDI for an
updated list on on this product line
expansion the far right-hand side then
lists are my cell products this is our
custom reprogramming this is highly
highly customizable we can do ipsc
reprogramming from a donor of choice
customer choice we can go ahead and
gently engineer that line we can
differentiate that lines or any of any
of those three subdivisions so it's
really customizable um this is a custom
order so it's where you contact our team
we then go down the road making those
cells for you but keep it straight what
we end up doing here is that I cell
models are representative models
off-the-shelf the DDPs of the diversity
of disease portfolio those can be a
mixture of off-the-shelf or
differentiated to order then the my cell
is really population specific models
which are custom manufacturing alright
we're going to really limit a strong and
continual effort to partner with a
variety of platform providers see arrows
reagent providers because the cells are
just one part of the equation you really
have to have the material to use and
interrogate the cells but really be of
any use for you so again we've made a
lot of effort throughout application
group to develop protocols and
applications for use of these cells so
chances are if you want to use them in
an assay we've already done it or can
direct you to somebody who has done it
there's no need to reinvent the wheel
but and those efforts are really headed
up by application development team it's
a team of nine I think actually now 11
scientists we've got a broad set of
experience from academia to drug
development through CRO s and a number
of early wins in their applications
whether it's miniaturizing the 1536 well
absence developing new assays functional
assays based on to cardiac hypertrophy
or April ear Elise Alzheimer's or
various functional toxicity outputs such
as a new right growth or cellular
electrophysiology again it's a team
that's at the disposal of our customers
right there well versed in our product
line however we're going to focus today
on the I saw cardiomyocytes so again
either human cardiomyocytes highly pure
and they come in unit sizes that will
plate at minimum in 96 384 or 1536 well
played so you're able to plan your
experiments based on the units of cells
that you order we've got a broad
customer publication base with greater
than 40 publications and we're really
utilized by over ninety percent of the
top pharmaceutical companies really the
value of these cells is then shown in
this next slide slide 10 so if we could
pop out here for a second to a video
that will show be a spontaneously
beating cardiomyocytes
you
all right Thank You Rachel um so that
that that that image there really sums
up the value of the cardiomyocytes that
beating exemplifies that they've got the
relevant biology they've got the native
processes that will then enable
downstream use all right all right so
this is one characterization slide that
we have for the cardiomyocyte just
really kind of set the stage if you look
on the upper left-hand graph and this
just exemplifies a whole genome
expression profile and it's meant to
show that the balloon of red lines
overlap these look at the transcription
profile at 30 days post differentiation
versus another 90 days and culture to
the fact that those lines overlap
indicates that we've got very stable
expression profile over 90 days they
trended those two lines trend very along
with the dotted line which is expression
profile from adult tissue so we've got
stable expression of values of stable
expression as well as relevant cardiac
expression so they're making what they
should make the protein expression image
in the right hand side again shows high
purity of cells as well as the
sarcomeric organization of the set of
the proteins within the cells upper
right hand side shows a graph from
seahorse bioscience showing that the
mitochondria are active so a basic
component of cardiac physiology is
active mitochondria and they are
activity sells more right-hand side is
just a schematic to illustrate the
biochemical processes are in place and
the lower middle graph shows that you've
got the appropriate EC or excitation
contraction coupling so electrical
defense of the membrane are transferred
through calcium transients in the
contraction it really has a full suite
of
functionality for testing all right you
can take my word for it or you can go to
our publication of database we've got
well over 40 publications that go as
family the gap from basic
characterization to a variety way of
ways of toxicity testing as well as
disease modeling and phenotypic
screening so I strongly encourage you to
to visit that if you have additional
questions about items that were not
covering in today's about talking okay
i'm pressing next one coming up a little
slow here there you go all right so jump
down into into the toxicity testing to
really set the stage here when I go over
a little type of a little bit of the
terminology so first on target toxic
sorry on target toxicity here the
molecule hits the target but has
unintended adverse events so for example
potassium channel antagonists were
developed early on to be anti-arrhythmic
well it turns out to actually employ
rhythmic this comes because we didn't
have a good understanding of the biology
at the time motor development another
example would be kinase inhibitors and
are used to disrupt targeted pathways
and cancer cells but those same pathways
a present and cardiac cells thus we've
got an overlapping biology unintended
toxicity there I off target toxicity is
where the molecule hits something
completely different than it was
intended to hit so examples would be
targeting h 1 receptors they end up
blocking her channels and can be coy
rhythmic secondly a more recent example
would be where activated t-cells that
targeted cancer cells actually cross
reacted with the cardiac Titan protein
and cause deaths and the clinical trials
so the off target toxicity or on target
toxicity has these adverse events the
bottom line for this is that in order to
accurately predict this toxicity you've
got to have a prep that covers all of
the relevant
biology and functionality and that's
where the ISIL cardiomyocytes come in
two main classes of toxicity that one
will be able to test here would be
functional toxicity where I at least
define that as an acute effect on the
electrical and mechanical function so
that can be left for the vesicle
membrane the calcium signaling or that
mechanical event of contractility
structural events are really where the
primary effective on a general cellular
process that may ultimately lead to a
functional consequence and again to
cover both of these toxicities you've
got to have that relevant cell system
the National cardiomyocytes can provide
that system in a variety of ways from a
structural toxicity standpoint you've
got a variety of endpoints in a variety
of platforms which with which you can
test for structural toxicity the
functional toxicity again where you're
testing that EC coupling those those
again can be broken down into discrete
events that can be tested through a
multitude of platforms and because
you've got the full functionality in a
single package you can now test how
surrogate structural markers and end up
various functional markers can really be
a surrogate markers for each other so
you can address through phenotypic
screening all of these endpoints and
similar and single or relatively few
number of assays I think that Matt will
really go into ways that they're looking
at this and Genentech is looking at this
taking advantage of the co evault
evolution of the cells as well as the
multiplex platforms all right that's
that's really the overview of the ISL
cardiomyocytes I've got a couple of
minutes here that I'd like to finish up
with using our new product I sell
cardiomyocytes squared as well as some
data on serum-free recording conditions
so the first thing to talk about with
when we come out with a new product is
why
I why did we do that well it's really a
response to customer requests of our
needs I think that's a polite way of
saying demands nasally come down to they
want less handling and shorter culture
times and the reasons for those are
fairly obvious so our answer to that was
the ISIL cardiomyocyte squared it's the
same starting material of ISIL
cardiomyocytes so it's the same cell
let's give the same cell type it comes
in the same format which cryopreserved
unit size is a single plate the
advantage here is that it's ready to use
within four days and that's really hit
home on this slide where we see the
original version I saw cardiomyocytes
you have really a 14-day incubation time
with media changes every other day a day
14 your guarantee that you're going to
have stable electrophysiological
functionality the ISIL cardiomyocytes
squared shortens that till four day
protocol all right and you've only got
media changes every day so it's it's a
minute or absolute not every day it's
still every other day so it's really one
to two media changes so what you see
here then is really a drastic reduction
in a the turnaround time and be the
amount of handling that one has with
these cells we've developed another
protocol with you cells the four-day
protocol is shown in the upper subway
diagram here where it's a monday to
friday protocol so you need to answer
quickly you can do that monday to friday
you don't have any weekend work however
the beauty of these cells is that
they're stable and culture and so you
can extend that sa window over for
several days if you have multiple
experiments to do to avoid weekend work
then we developed a wednesday to
wednesday protocol that's shown down on
the lower
more diagrams where again you can thaw
the cells on a Wednesday change the
media on Friday there's no weekend work
change the media again the next day or
at the end of the weekends or monday um
and then again change on Tuesday and on
day seven which will be wednesday you're
ready to go and you can very easily have
three days of recording again without
any weekend work so the main thrusts of
these new protocols is to shorten the
amount of time decreasing amount of
handling and get rid of any type of
weekend work I think we're pretty
successful at that all right we've got
just a little bit of data here and urge
you to contact application support or
technical support for from water data on
this but we've got protocols for using
them in peanuts recordings as we can see
here brief screenshots how do we get the
expected responses across a variety of
chemical classes there's a great demand
for meam recordings and so we also have
an off-the-shelf MVM recording protocol
and again we've got the expected
responses in chemical space another
customer demand request has been to
develop serum-free recording conditions
and we've successfully done that as well
so here again I can see the standard
subway diagrams so the workflows and a
four day or seven day I'm very similar
um the obvious change here is that you
need to do an immediate change before
you start to culture the cells to put
them into that serum free media again
very limited amount of data here but
that we're showing we have more at home
office here but again you see standard
physiological waveforms in standard
media versus serum free media and you've
got very even beating rates very
consistent betray a very low coefficient
variability so it's even beat rate very
reproducible
again we've got a robust responses for
either workflow cross chemical space
here we're looking at her channel block
on the left in normal media versus
serum-free media as well as receptor
activation on the right again in serum
containing or serum free media so we
really developed a faster workflow as
well as workloads conducive to doing
your experiments without the specter of
protein binding alright to summarize
simply refer back to the overview slide
so from a CDI perspective we've
established ourselves as the leading
provider by PSC drive cell types I think
we have a first class product first
class support and together that really
enables success for the customers the
cardiomyocytes those of you that know me
you've been hearing me how to be a bout
this for years but they really do
recapitulate the human biology they're
easy to use and the most important thing
is that their feel validated so we have
a strong customer database that one can
refer to for validation and
qualification of the various endpoints
and uses um we've got the new products I
sell cardiomyocytes squared as well as
serum-free recording conditions so I've
gone a bit over my time I apologize to
Matt but I'd like to turn it over to
Matt now where he can really go into the
practical use and and how their company
um conducts their in vitro toxicology
testing so thank you and I look forward
to your questions at the end of the
seminar
thanks for the invitation dr. Hansen he
need full on slides here yeah I have to
say that the I'm not growing from a deep
well of experience here at Genentech yet
I've been here for about six months and
I was kind of brought on board
specifically to work with these cells
and technologies that enable us to
record from them but my well is a bit
deeper for the cells themselves which
I've been working with for a better part
of five years and so I have watched the
technology platform to grow around the
cells so that the outline of the talk is
here I'll talk briefly about our group
at Genentech and then how the ice I'll
cardiomyocytes fit into our work here
and then really the emphasis will be on
the methods we use to record from the
cells I'll talk about a couple you use
cases for different projects here at
Genentech but again these are just a
more of a context to show how we work
with these cells than a an explanation
of the projects themselves so and then
this will be a good transition into a
couple different topics the first is an
emphasis on how we're trying to
multiplex more information from single
assay plates and this will also form the
background for an initial evaluation of
the new product that dr. Anson described
which is the ISO cardiomyocytes squared
so the investigative toxicology group
that I work in and Genentech
is really the the research arm of this
safety assessment department we we focus
on in vitro cell based assays hopefully
plate based assays but we we work with
project teams in all stages of
development from early research to to
early clinical we are by no means the
filter through which all compounds at
Genentech must pass through were really
really called in for cause usually to
try to figure out a mechanism of
toxicity so we and it's also important
to point out that we outsource a lot of
routine screening such as heard binding
nav cap binding to CR OS our emphasis is
on really developing new assays to
elucidate mechanisms of toxicity and and
as such we really have a mandate to
evaluate new technology improve upon it
incorporate new cell based products into
our workflow and hopefully this allows
us to increase the amount of data we can
get out of cells or particular platforms
and also increase the turnaround for our
project the cardiovascular side of the
investigative toxicology is is smaller
of course the real stars of the show
here are the cells and indeed the ICL
cardiomyocytes are really the cell that
we that we use the most we have a lot of
momentum with these cells but they are
remarkably robust in most of the assays
that we use them for and that will be
the rest of the talk I'll show you a lot
of that we do work with some other types
of cardiomyocytes from rat and mouse
this is usually to address
species-specific talks issues but the
human ipsc derived cardiomyocytes are
really the most adaptable to a variety
of assays we are well equipped with with
systems that are broadly applicable for
different cell types hepatocyte immune
cells such as high content imaging do
some next-gen sequencing we have lots of
plate readers but the emphasis of our
work with ISL cardiomyocytes has really
been on platforms that directly address
their functional beating phenotyping and
the two main ways that we've done that
are with multi-electrode array and more
recently with some video analysis of the
cardiomyocytes beating I won't go on
here at length because Blake has
addressed many of the advantages of
these cell types they're basically to us
a comprehensive in vitro human cardiac
phenotype down to the actual functional
beating for us the real advantage of
these cells is the low vile to vile and
well too well variability that we see in
their properties but perhaps most
importantly the fact that these are just
so robust over time in culture because
while some of our work is is dealing
with acute ion channel blockade effects
that you can record in in an hour a lot
of our work really requires that we
study these cells in the presence of a
compound for one week or two weeks
during which we need the properties of
these cells to be stable there there are
always concerns about new products you
know some of the arguments levied
against human ipsc derive cardiomyocytes
or that they're arguably young compared
to an adult cardiomyocyte the
spontaneous beating bothers some people
it's unlike an isolated adult
ventricular cardiomyocyte but again we
really love the fact that these beat
spontaneously
really the proof is in the pudding here
which is that there are now numerous
studies and publications that have shown
both for arrhythmia prediction and and
for structural talks the productivity of
these cells is remarkably good the
spontaneous beating is really helpful
for for non-invasive assays again
that'll be the emphasis of my talk and I
just to address the the stability of
these cells and culture and the
stability of the beating properties I'd
like to submit a kind of half-baked
plate that we've dubbed stumpy in the
lab which is just a 96 standard 96-well
plate that is full of some leftover
cardiomyocytes we plated some other
plates that we had a purpose for and
then we had some leftover ones these
were plated it's called stumpy because
we only made it halfway through the
plate before we ran out of cells and the
cells were actually played it a little
bit thinly but I've had ideas over the
past 70 days about what I was going to
do with this plate some fancy
pharmacology I wanted to throw at it but
I really never got around to it but what
we have been doing with this plate is is
recording its beat properties in all of
the wells that are full of cells
periodically and feeding it every two or
three days it's it's been neglected
experimentally but it's really served as
a test of how robust and and the the
longevity of these cells and culture you
can see it at lower left the beats per
minute between when we first started
recording at about 11 days and now which
is about 70 days post plating has
hovered around 35 beats per minute these
things are still going strong the
contraction duration which is
to lower right has been around 350
milliseconds I'll get into how we've
recorded these but the emphasis here is
that these are remarkably stable in
their phenotype and this is really
important for our work because we we
have been asked to do 30 days studies
with these cells I'll get into some
basic protocols that really apply to
most of the the assays that we use so I
don't have to go into these for each of
the platforms oh these cells are thawed
and played directly into the multi-well
assay plates usually at around 40 to
50,000 cells per well the standard I
cells require a couple weeks of recovery
and which allows them to form a
sensation and stabilize their heat
properties that two weeks is usually
fine for us they're maintained and and
recorded in medium with serum although
as as Blake said for shorter experiments
you can you can do without the serum we
just don't do that for for experiments
that we're we're monitoring the cells
for a week or two because the serum
seems to be important for long-term
stability of eating we feed these cells
every two or three days and refresh the
the compound as well if we're post-dose
and we generally refresh the medium the
day before before an experiment because
we want to give the cells a little time
to settle down before we start recording
all of the experiments I'll show are
done at 37 degrees and five percent co2
either because the instrument is is in
an incubator or we're bringing the five
percent co2 to the incubator vertu the
instrument need to go into the rest of
that that's so really our wheelhouse for
functional studies has been
multi-electrode array recordings so as
blake said you see these cells into a
petri dish
and given enough time they form a
spontaneously beating sensation there's
no reason you can't have some field
potential electrodes embedded in the
cell culture substrate and these are
generally coplanar with a cell culture
surface they're not invasive and you can
see in the middle there a micrograph of
a monolayer of cells growing on a multi
electrode array in a petri dish
essentially and these electrodes thus
serve as an in vitro ECG so during the
spontaneous feeding you get many of the
same waveform features as you would see
in an ECG including a QRS depolarization
spike a repolarization bump or a T wave
and the duration or the interval in
between those two features is a
surrogate of the QT interval will call a
field potential variation to be safe
here and of course you can get a beep
period by looking at the time in between
the depolarization spikes and you can
get a spike amplitude which generally
reflects the amount of current that you
see during a V polarization that would
be through sodium channel there are some
advantages of having a grid of
electrodes in a given well or dish one
is that the redundancy gives you a
better chance of finding a teeway that
the software can read the other is that
the depolarization spike will reach the
electrodes at different times which
allows you to actually track the
propagation of the electrical like
excitation across the grid and this
allows you to extract a conduction
velocity from the different electrodes
so the system
that we use the most here in house as
the axion multiwell MEA system MEA
systems have been around in some form of
a nut or another for roughly four
decades but what accion is done is turn
this into a legitimate multi-well
platform so the system itself is shown
it up or left it's small for a plate
reader it's environmentally and
temperature controlled the plate that we
use most often is a 48 well plate in
which each well has 16 non-invasive
field potential electrodes and a 4 by 4
grid again a strong advantage of the
multi-electrode array approach is that
because these electrodes are
non-invasive you get cereal recordings
from the same plate so we can pop this
this plate into the recorder every day
for a month if you want to typically
will do closely spaced recordings you
know for the first few hours and then
maybe monitor the plate once a day for
for longer term recordings that there's
high spatial and time resolution so
we're sampling at 20 kilohertz which
gives you really find fine resolution of
the depolarization features again the
multiple electrodes give you information
about the propagation of excitation
across the grid and the mono layer of
cells makes it easy to find a good T
wave for compounds that actually move
the field potential duration in one
direction or another another strong
advantage of this system is that all of
the wells are read in parallel in
contrast to objective based methods of
looking at cardiomyocytes so essentially
we're done with a plate read after two
to five minutes and this means that post
dose our compound exposure times are
identical for all of the different
some limitations which are really being
addressed actively by the manufacturer
that the and I'll talk about some of
these later or that the 48 well played
is opaque so you're kind of flying blind
in terms of whether your cells are there
you can see it functionally of course in
terms of being able to pace the cells
MEA electrodes are a little inefficient
because of their size again this is
something that the will be addressed in
future iterations of plates and for us
the field potential that we're measuring
it is in concept upstream of some of the
targets that we'd like to scream
although I'll explain that essentially
almost everything feeds back on field
potential the system has seen great use
recently as predictive of clinical
arrhythmia you can do a google search
for the hesi cipa initiative essentially
if you look at bottom left you're
looking at the raw field potential
signal from one electrode in one well
and you can see the spontaneous
depolarizations the repolarization bumps
are kind of lost in the turtle scale
here but at left is pre dose in the
center you see the signal in the
presence of a Hurt Locker cisapride you
can see the beat period is extended and
there are some little aberrant
depolarizations you might call an
ectopic beads or after depolarizations
that arise in the presence of cisapride
and you can make dose-response curves
for heard blockers or calcium blockers
sodium channel blockers system has seen
great use for this purpose and indeed we
we do use it for this purpose at
Genentech some of our compounds show
obvious ion channel blockade often we
know this because we screen them for her
or nav or have binding this is a
project at Genentech where where we do
see those effects raw data traces are
shown at top at the left you see a raw
field potential signal pre dose and then
at right post dose with a first
generation compound from this project
and you can see in the presence of the
compound there are ectopic feeds that
arise the peak period is extended you
see notched T waves or after
depolarizations at bottom left you see a
an overlay of the pre and post dose
waveform and you can see in red that the
waveform and the presence of drug shows
a delayed repolarization feature and you
can plot this at bottom right as a dose
response curve for for the QT interval
or field potential duration you can see
that the generation one compound does
have some issues at 10 micro molar we're
really at two hundred percent of the
baseline QT value but subsequent
iterations from from chemistry at new
compounds for this particular target
have reduced the the ion channel
blockade and thus the prolongation of
the field potential duration more often
than not however we're we're not dealing
with compounds that have obvious ion
channel blockade problems perhaps
because these are d risk earlier on
through outsource ion channel binding
assays so this is a particular project
that I'll really spend most of the rest
of the talk talking about because if it
helps me highlight some of the assays
that we'll use to look at beating of
these cardiomyocytes and also ways that
we've multiplexed information that we
can get from from a single well and from
a single plate this this project came to
us from really at the development stage
because their first of all their
competitor drugs that target the same
pathway not the same target that lead to
cardiac issues specifically left
ventricular ejection fraction issues but
in house in in preclinical studies we
observed decreased heart to brain ratios
and some ultra structural signs of
cardiomyocyte atrophy in seven-day rat
studies and so we were your hand of
these compounds to see what the direct
effect on on cardiomyocytes might be and
whether these were consistent with what
we see in in vivo studies so this is
showing a kind of a first pass a say
that we use for for most of the
compounds we get which is just a screen
for outright cytotoxicity this is a
chemiluminescence assay for ATP content
that we typically run after three or
seven day exposures to compounds
specifically this is a cell tighter glow
assay and these compounds which I'm
calling GX and we're talking about GX 1
+ GX 2 here are not cytotoxic by this
measure after three or seven day
exposures but these are our
dose-response curves for ATP content the
positive controls are staurosporine and
you can see if this causes significant
loss of ATP at either seven days or
three days GX one in orange and GX two
in green are healthy all the way out to
50 micro molar so we don't really see
any scientist direct cytotoxicity
however if we if we look at the
functional properties we see some market
problems again the MEA system is really
our first pass for functional studies
I'm showing raw traces at top for one
electrode
one well pre and post dose with 30
micromolar gx1 and you can see a very
regular beating pre dose one day post
dose you start to see now both an
increase in NB trait but the more
profound effect that that really
manifests over the course of the week is
a decrease in spike amplitude to the
point where after six days we're just
down to little blips on the radar if you
overlay the traces pre and post dosa as
you see it right there there is a
decrease in the QT interval but clearly
that is not the largest effect that we
would be concerned about these cells
just are kind of going off radar in
terms of spike amplitude dose-response
curves and time courses are shown at the
bottom spike amplitude is in the middle
beats per minute is at the bottom for
for three different compounds from this
series and they're color-coded for dose
30 micro molar is in orange and one
micromolar is in blue you can see
there's a clear dose dependence and time
dependence to this effect where for gx1
for example after seven days in culture
were really down to about thirty percent
the spike amplitude on average and the
compounds differ in the magnitude of
effect but qualitatively they all act in
Billy the same way so this is an effect
that generally you might say is
consistent with the with the in vivo
atrophy that we see it is however a
little hand wavy to to be talking about
the field potential effect when you're
when you're thinking about atrophy which
you would really think is something
downstream of that so we are interested
in in screening for or the contraction
itself again the you know the excitation
is due to
ion channels that are present in the
cell cell membrane and these the
electrical cycle was really thought to
to drive a calcium release and then of
course the contraction so so it's
comforting to be able to directly
observe contraction and we have a way of
doing that I should say that having
screens a lot of possible I am handling
targets upstream of the sarcomere itself
virtually everything feeds back on the
field potential so i would i'd say
somewhere around ninety five percent of
possible targets in the cardiomyocyte
can be detected by MEA but there's
something very comfortable about
directly observing the contraction and
there are some examples of compounds
that it really kind of decoupled a
contraction from the excitation levis
tetanus is really the poster child for
this which is something that kills
contraction but leaves the electrical
beat cycle relatively intact the system
that we've had the most experience with
thus far for looking directly at
contraction is the cell EG pulse
instrument this is a an instrument that
just automated in an automated fashion
takes a multi-well plate and goes from
well too well records video and using
pixel tracking derives a contraction
signal it's it's directly looking at the
contraction which is something that we
like it's automated in a nice way
environmentally controlled and a really
nice thing about this is that it uses
standard multi-well plates which we can
then pass off to multiplex with high
content imaging and i'll talk a little
bit about how this can be used also with
MEA a minor limitation here is that it
reads one well at a time so the total
retime for the plate can be quite long
so you do end up with non-identical
compound exposure time
the the readouts here are our
contraction amplitude the duration of
contraction I'm showing a raw trace at
lower right you can feed braids out of
these you can look at arrhythmia of
course and and of course you and you can
derive a percentage of the cells in the
visual field that are actually moving so
we've we've run these GX compounds on
the pulse and and we see effects that
really mirror those that we've observed
with the MEA system these are raw data
signals at the top pre dose at the top
left and then at different times post
dose going to the right and by one day
post dose we've really gone down to
roughly twenty percent of the pre dose
contraction amplitude and the
dose-response curves that we get from
you so I look remarkably similar to what
we get with NBA and you see those at the
bottom we've looked a little bit at a
recovery from the compounds although we
need to look at this it's slightly
better time resolution but if you wash
these sell the compounds out after a
week of exposure they do recover slowly
we're looking here tx1 the top and gx2
at the bottom credos and then eight days
post dose in the middle and then four
days post wash out some of the amplitude
is recovered but not all of it is
recovered so this is not an
instantaneous recovery like you would
see with some sort of cute ion channel
antagonism and this is just further
evidence that we've done something
substantial to these cells structurally
you might think that if if this is
consistent with a trophy perhaps we
would observe some effects on on the
integrity of the monolayer we can we can
address this by using the the array of
electrodes as I described before and and
look at the propagation of these
spontaneous beads across across the grid
of elect
you're looking at the propagation maps
at the top here at 72 hours post-dose
with vehicle at upper left and then in
the presence of GX 1 or 2 X 2 and middle
and right respectively and the range of
colors that you see here is really
representative of the speed and they're
similar for all of these so the the rate
of propagation is really not affected by
these compounds if you look at bottom
right this is conduction velocity pre
dose in the empty bars and the filled
bars or post dose and really there's no
there's no change the bottom left this
is to emphasize that these recordings
are done at a time when we've reduced
the contraction amplitude down to
between twenty and forty percent so
while we're affecting these cells
functionally we're not really disrupting
the monolayer in any substantial way and
this is also consistent with the idea
that we're not really seeing cell death
but so as I said at the beginning of the
talk a real emphasis of ours it has been
on multiplexing different endpoints we
were comfortable running these
experiments in parallel but a dream of
mine is to be able to use a single plate
to get all of these endpoints and in
fact a recent development a taxi on has
made some of this possible which is the
development of a transparent mea in a 40
well 48 well format that's shown it up
or left we've had the good fortune to to
work with some of the prototypes and the
beauty here is that we can get MEA data
and also pulse contraction data from the
same plate and the other thing I should
say is that the transparent plate allows
us to send this off to high content
imaging when we're done with the other
acid and so I'll let lab roots take you
to a video of these cells contracting in
real time
transparent mea plate
you
and so we don't do these recordings
simultaneously we do have to cycle
between the two instruments but we can
get to both data types from the same
plate and this also serves as as the
starting point for for our evaluation of
the ice l squared product and this is
looking at the pulse properties of this
tmea again contraction by pixel analysis
I'm showing raw data traces for each of
the 48 wells laid out it as the geometry
of the wells would be in the plate and
you can see that the timing of the
beating is remarkably consistent across
all of the wells I've analyzed the the
averages for beat periods the duration
peak amplitude at the bottom these are
in histogram form with all of the
averages for the 48 wells and you can
see that the distribution here is really
remarkably tight particularly for
betrayed and beat duration and we've I'm
comfortable with the distribution for
peak amplitude to and but generally this
is a property that's a little more
variable for for for video recordings in
MEA i should say we've done some some
initial tests to to see whether these
signals covary when we apply some usual
ion channel blocker suspects we're
looking at a heard blocker at top 40 31
and at the bottom is a calcium channel
blocker and the feta team and these are
filled potential recordings and
contraction recordings from the same
plate so pre dose baseline in each case
is shown at left and then post dose is
at right and you can see then for both
of these compounds the effects are
remarkably similar so we're pretty
excited that we can get these these two
types of data in parallel from the same
plate and then there's of course a lot
of excitement that we can then pass
these plates off
to a high content imager to look at look
at things like sarcomere structure this
is just a first pass attempt using like
emea with a couple really common labels
the first is Daffy which is a nuclear
stain and blue and then alpha acting in
which seems stains the sarcomere in
green and you can see a nice striated
sarcomere structure at right we're still
working out it's a little hard to see
the definition of a given cell these
cells are really packed in this
particular plate so we can probably play
them a little more Finley or use
something that would outline the cells
in a way that would let us define them a
little bit better but this is really in
progress and will certainly be optimized
over time another way of multiplexing
that we've explored recently is purely
electrical multiplexing we've we've had
a good fortune lately to to demo a new
impedance base system from asya this is
the Excel against RTC a cardio ECR
instrument asya has been in the
impedance business for a long time I
think predating the the advent of stem
cell-derived cardiomyocytes but as they
realized that these systems are a way of
recording the real time beating and
carting my sites they've just really
piled on me the acronyms to indicate the
added functionality impedance I should I
should talk a little bit about but you
can probably google this there are a lot
of webinars about how impedance works to
record the real time beating essentially
you're looking at the resistance through
the monolayer of cardiomyocytes and the
cells themselves forma basically a
constant impedance but the movement of
the cells during beating causes small
fluctuations in this signal
and you can see this if a graph it right
that allow you to monitor the
contraction in real time in addition to
the effects on on the beating you can
look at effects on the number of cells
that are remaining on the surface
because if you have a compound that
causes cell death you really reduce the
overall impedance and so it's nice to be
able to monitor this in parallel so
essentially a system like this gives you
viata ability to to monitor both the
real time beating the integrity of the
monolayer and what they've added to this
most recent version is a couple field
potential life throws so you're really
getting three types of electrical
information or I should say a few early
electrical multiplexing with a single
plate again the nice thing here is that
the the contraction signal and field
potential are recorded simultaneously
you can run the system in an incubator
which is nice like the MEA system the
wells are read in pair and parallel so
that they're short played three times it
works well for stimulation a limitation
is this is a minor one but it's you're
not looking directly at contraction this
is sort of an electrical derivative
contraction unlike the video analysis
there are only two field potential
electrodes / well so versus a true grid
of electrodes you have a harder time
finding a good T wave shape so this
would not be our first pass for for
Cutie effects and because you only have
two electrodes you don't get a
propagation pattern and the cell i
should say the plates are opaque so you
can't follow up with a high content
imaging but we were excited to test this
system in it seems to fit well with this
particular project because of the
endpoints that you get so and here's
some preliminary data with the gx1
compound i should also emphasize this as
using the iso
squared products the these signals are
reported in parallel again in red we're
looking at the impedance signal or what
they call cell index and below that is
the simultaneously recorded field
potential pre dose is on the left and
seven days post dose with 30 micro molar
gx1 is shown at the right and see that
both of these signals are profoundly
reduced over time the time course and
dose dependence for both of these are
shown at the bottom so it's bottom left
we're looking at the impedance
contraction amplitude and you can see
dose-response curves and time courses
that are similar to what we saw before
with the pulse the field potential data
is a little noisier but differences are
significant and the trends are similar
and not shown in the center and again an
important piece of the puzzle is at
bottom right which is is that we can
monitor the integrity of the monolayer
by looking at the total cell the total
impedance across the monolayer and these
compounds don't have much of an effect
this is important because it's in
contrast to some other compounds that
are known to be cardiotoxic we're using
doxorubicin here as an example the again
post those verses pre dose we see a
profound reduction in the presence of
doxorubicin in this case after two days
and the time course for the for the
reduction in contraction amplitude is
shown at bottom left looks somewhat
similar qualitatively to what we see
with gx1 but what you see at bottom
right is is the overall impedance or
overall cell index which again is a
measure of the number of remaining cells
or the integrity of the monolayer and
and the time course of this is exactly
the same as we see with the contraction
amplitude itself which really tells you
that's a reduction in amplitude of the
contraction it's just because we have
fewer cells contributing to that
signal and this just shows schematically
the difference between something like
doxorubicin and CX 1 which is that for
doxorubicin that the decreasing
contracts and amplitude is due to loss
of cells most likely where CX 1 we we
have an intact monolayer we just have
weaker contractions and the last thing
I'll show here is is a ham-fisted
attempt to to address this the
possibility that we're we're seeing
atrophy of these cells so so one
alternate hypothesis is that we have
some sort of reduction in the number of
ion channels or perhaps driving force
for ionic current that is upstream of
the effects on contraction and perhaps
if we can we can stimulate the cells
electrically we can recover some of that
contraction amplitude that doesn't seem
to be the case so we're showing credos
baseline that upper left and then 14
days post ghosts with GX 1 and bottom
right you can see the beginning of the
bottom right trace spontaneous beating
as is much weaker than we see two weeks
before freedos condition and then the
red bars are indicating where we've
stimulated these cells in an attempt to
see if we can get larger contractions
and you see that we essentially don't
this is shown at bottom right and bar
graph form with credos baseline at left
contraction amplitude as what we're
showing here and then 14 days later a
pre pre stimulation amplitude is shown
in pink and then the two red bars are
two different strengths of stimulus so
we can't really recover the contraction
amplitude so I can wrap up now sorry for
going a little bit over but this this
talk hopefully has highlighted the
numerous ways we we can use these cells
and how adaptable they are two
particular assays they really are a rich
sort of real-time functional phenotype
for for human cardiomyocytes
the low well too well variability and
the stability over time has really
allowed us to to adapt these cells to
our purposes here and a number of
different types of toxicities so
including acute ion channel blockade but
also as as Blake called this structural
toxicities that would take a week or two
to manifest and hopefully I've shown you
that an emphasis here is really on
multiplexing different functional and
structural endpoints from the same plate
and really the robustness and longevity
of the cell product here is what would
allow some of this to happen and the i'm
certainly not acting alone here we've
have a lot of help in terms of career
development and product support and of
course were khurshid if of all the demo
equipment that we've gotten a try and i
should call particular attention to my
RA who's the first name here he's done a
lot of the fabulous bench work that I've
shown that's Julia hidin and I think of
that we can we can start taking
questions excellent presentation dr.
Brock thanks for bringing that
information to us before I get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button the lower left of
presentation window will get to as many
questions as we can our first question
is can you comment on maturation of I
cells compared to native adult cardiac
myocytes this one is for Blake and then
we'll have Matt comment also you'll have
Matt comment also
alright thank you Judy um you know I
think Matt touch on this a little bit as
well um you can see from a lot of the
images and just the the morphology of
the cells if there's going to be
differences in morphology there's going
to be differences in really how the
cells line up with each other so you
know versus the butt rod-shaped vs water
splayed out shape I think the bottom
line is that there's definitely
differences between the adult
cardiomyocytes and the ipsc
cardiomyocytes most of that is going to
be due to the way that their culture so
to e cultures against a non yielding
plastic substrate the important thing
though is to know what the boundaries of
those limitations are and not to ask too
much of the cells I think we've been
very good in defining those boundaries
and showing that these are and improved
testing reagent over what's currently
out there so it Matt if you'd have
anything to counter or add to that
please please comment yeah sure so I
think there are a couple ways that I can
address that the first is that the
starting point for an adult
cardiomyocyte and a stem cell-derived
cardiomyocyte are just radically
different so the stem cell-derived
cardiomyocytes have advantages and in
terms of plating these things basically
starting in suspension whereas you an
adult kardi myocyte you have to pull out
of an adult organ and study in isolation
which is arguably more disruptive so
it's really hard to know what the exact
phenotype of an adult cardiomyocyte is
because of that I think another thing is
that that as with many things the
technology will catch up with with the
cells
I know the people are hard at work on on
finding ways to get the cardiomyocytes
both to to line up on something like an
Emmy a plate which would give you a
essentially a more adult morphology of
the cardiomyocyte and and they're also
attempts of course it to bring these
into a 3d structure so I think no one is
no one should be a hundred percent
satisfied with with the product and as a
result the field really moves forward I
think we will see advances in the in the
platforms and in the types of wells that
we record these cells that will give
them a more adult morphology and maybe
function
k this question is for Matt how do you
quantify or with macaque tivity in MEA
EAD like beats for example yeah it's
it's an active area of thought and n
development I think it at mva
manufacturers it's tricky because you
are you're looking at high time
resolution signals and it's much easier
to kind of train train the software on
things that are regular the approach in
the SE sip initiative for example has
been to score a bruh Leo's is just kind
of plus or minus it would be nice
however to to be able to say how many
EAP use you have herbs think again this
is if you can see it with the human eye
you can probably eventually train
software to detect these things and
quantify them presently because most of
our our projects here are things like I
showed last which are things like easy
to quantify in terms of spike amplitude
we haven't really dug into how to
quantify a good news but I know it's an
active area of development at the the
platform manufacturers so that that's a
little hand wavy but it's it's not our
biggest concern so it's not really kind
of at the top of our to-do list
okay this one's for Matt also is the
corre- I can say a better predictor of
QT prolongation than telemetry test well
I think the jury is still out the I
don't you know here we are at genentech
we are not going to get away from from
things like telemetry tests we would
hope that's that an in vitro assay like
the MEA system and the effects on cutie
in an assay like that would help us
guide what compound made it to tell Emma
tree so I'm not a hundred percent I
don't think we're going to get away
anytime soon from animal studies we're
really just trying to to kind of pick
pick out bad players a little earlier in
an in vitro assay I don't think one is
one is necessarily more predictive than
the other but but really the hope in
using a human cell type is that we kind
of get around species specific issues so
I think they both have their their
strengths and don't think one is really
necessarily intended to replace the
other we just hope that we can kind of
synthesized the two assays to to come up
with a more accurate overall picture
that's all we have time work for today
if we did not get to your question will
follow up with you via email
I would like to thank our speakers today
doctors Anson and Brock as well as our
sponsor cellular dynamics international
for making it possible to bring his
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through six months from this live
presentation you'll receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on lab routes comm
you're welcome to forward that
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time